all right jeffrey epstein's lover
jaslane maxwell was found guilty for her
role in the child sex trafficking ring
but will anyone else be charged brad
edwards is a civil rights attorney who
represented uh represents more than 50
of epstein's victims he joins me now are
any of any of your clients going to name
names of whether there was anyone else
involved in this operation other than
maxwell and epstein
are my clients going to name other other
people um yes i mean i think that that
is going to happen it would be
preferable if those people especially
now would come forward and and give us a
call and talk to us because
as we have seen by this verdict it's
never too late to be held accountable
and that's going to happen and it's
never too late to come forward and share
your story if you're a victim
no that's true and i guess for for your
uh clients the 50 of them or more uh
with this verdict did they feel like
there was some kind of justice that was
served obviously this was really uh late
justice this case should have been
prosecuted and investigated a long time
ago but uh did the this ruling and
verdict uh give them some kind of peace
of mind
this verdict did a lot for them i mean
look the government the way that they
were treated the first time around with
the jeffrey epstein case in florida uh
caused them to lose a lot of confidence
in the system and the government and
this went a long way toward resurrecting
that lost trust in all of them and like
one of my clients said last night we
finally feel like we matter i think
that's a really really important uh
comment and statement and it it's pretty
consistent throughout the 20 or more
clients that i've had a chance to speak
to since the verdict came out
brad there's some speculation that miss
maxwell in some effort to try to reduce
her sentence might actually expose
people who are involved as well and as
we've reported some of those people may
be very famous and wealthy maybe royals
do you think that she's going to
actually expose who was all involved in
this sex ring
well given maxwell had a chance for the
last 10 years to
tell all who she knew in fact there was
a time where she could have just simply
ratted out her boyfriend jeffrey epstein
and probably done pretty good for
herself and she didn't it doesn't seem
to me that she's the kind of person
who's going to turn rat now especially
on some of her good friends that's not
how she got where she is and honestly
she's the top of the pyramid
anybody that she rats out is someone
lower on the rungs than she is i can't
imagine that's really going to work down
her sentence too significantly
even if she were to do that
so brett i was a prosecutor for 10 years
and i tried a lot of cases like this
these child sexual assault cases and
they absolutely destroy little girls
it's not a short-term crime it's a crime
that lasts with them for their whole
lifetime and um i'm grateful that you
would represent you know 50 other young
women out there who had this happen to
them um how are they doing um are they
are they putting their lives together
right now can you give us a quick update
on how they're how they're doing
well as you know having been a former
prosecutor it's not a one-size-fits-all
um some of them are doing very well
considering but you know as you
mentioned it is essentially a life
sentence for most of them it's not pain
and suffering that just goes away even
with a verdict like this you know and so
i think i was asked uh previously about
uh the descendants that guilin maxwell
is likely to receive which in essence
will probably be a life sentence for her
but considering that she was directly or
indirectly the cause of a life sentence
of pain and suffering for dozens if not
hundreds of young women
it's as close to justice as as you can
imagine but some of my clients are doing
fairly well and some aren't
listen brad thanks for doing the work
and again you destroy little girls lives
when you sexually assault them no doubt
thanks for joining me tonight and thanks
for your work hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else